depuis une semaine sandrine l'amour
découvre le maraîchage 35 heures par
semaine employé par le bo 58 entreprise
née de l'initiative territoire 0
chômeurs de longue durée
à 42 ans chômage et chantiers
d'insertion derrière elle une nouvelle
vie commence pour cette ancienne
ouvrière dans l'industrie cadets en
usine
j'ai travaillé à philips jusqu'en 2008
et marche tourné entre philippe ses
looks mais du coup avec la crise maniez
moins de boulot donc voilà ça change la
vie de reprendre une activité
bâle 2 lever tous les matins de bonne
humeur parce qu'on a un travail
thierry sauvage lui est impliqué dans le
projet depuis le départ
formé à l'ébénisterie il a trouvé sa
place à la recyclerie de le bo après
deux ans et demi de chômage son
quotidien en est transformé sa changer
parce que je le retrouve déjà avec un
salaire ce que ge a pas rien c'est mieux
que d'être rsa ou pas avoir de revenus
et puis c'est un soleil quoi c'est plein
d'activités qui kiffent ont mis dans la
tête pourquoi rld et ne pas se retrouver
seul depuis février ce sont 60 de
contrat comme ceux de sandrine et
thierry qui ont été signés financé en
partie par les allocations chômage
l'entreprise abe d'emploi intervient
dans les secteurs de la motoculture à la
conciergerie des services sans
concurrence locale et qui permettent de
recréer de l'activité ou non une
dynamique voilà le territoire a répond
présent à ce projet
avec de multiples de vie qu'ont pu faire
sur les collectivités et particuliers
et puis les salariés jouent de plus en
plus le jeu de le bio et fiction un
dispositif de retour à l'emploi étape
pour permettre aux chômeurs de longue
durée de renouer avec le monde du
travail
après quelques mois le be2 l'une des
salariées a déjà quitté l'aventuré pour
un cdi